you know the other person that was an
important mentor to me was David milch
and you know he was one of those people
that would he would lay on the ground
there'd be a microphone on the ground
and he would dictate the show people
would wait around while he channeled
the show and he he believes
inspiration comes to prepared souls and
his whole thing was about that
connection can you open yourself up and
be so present and available that the
creativity comes and to trust that
and
you know he he always says uh you can't
think yourself into writing but you can
write yourself into thinking
so just start and it'll it'll just come
and so that was a a real lesson
for me